welcome to the show everybody friends
neighbors fellow countrymen we we begin
today with the esteemed mayor Pete
Buddha judge it's interesting to watch
Buddha judge because you see a man who
is trying to cultivate a brand as this
inclusive tolerant reasonable candidate
and yet also the locus one of the bunch
he wants to be all of those things and
those things don't really don't really
go together in the end and in a similar
way he's trying to be seen as nice and
relatable even while he is clearly
simmering with with rage and disgust
towards those people who don't think
like him and so there's this constant
tension with this guy that you can sense
and you can you could see it and hear it
by listening to him for speak for five
seconds it's it's so obvious here's a
great example and this isn't the one
that I want to focus on today but but
this just happened a few days ago so
it's worth mentioning Buddha judge did a
town hall on Saturday and during the
town hall he was asked by a pro-life
democrat there are still some of those
left apparently whether he thinks that
she a pro-life Democrat woman should be
welcomed and included in his party and
here's how that went
we have a question now from Christian
Day about abortion Christian I am a
proud pro-life democrat so do you want
the support of pro-life democrats to
promote pro-life democratic voters there
are about 21 million of us and if so
would you support more moderate platform
language in the Democratic Party to
ensure that the party of diversity of
inclusion really does include everybody
well I respect where you're coming from
and I hope to earn your vote but I'm not
going to try to earn your vote by
tricking you I am pro-choice and I
believe that a woman ought to be able to
make that decision here's what I
but I know that the difference of
opinion that you and I have is one that
we have come by honestly and the best
that I can offer and it may win your
vote and if not I understand the best I
can offer is that if we can't agree on
where to draw the line the next best
thing we can do is agree on who should
draw the line and in my view it's the
woman who's faced with that decision in
her own life
so you notice there he never said yes of
course you're welcome and there was a
follow up to where because he dodged the
question basically and she was asked
again directly do you think the Democrat
Party should add language to its
platform saying that pro-life democrats
are welcome and he refused to say that
yes i think they should be welcome point
being no you're not welcome you are not
welcome that was his message he a man to
this pro-life woman said you are not
welcome which which is true they'd
reveals something about himself but it's
also true than probe that pro-life
people absolutely are not welcome to the
Democrat Party so what I would say to
that woman and to any other lingering
pro-lifers and Democrat party you are
definitely unwelcome if you didn't get
the hint yet and you've been unwelcome
in that party for decades now so I'd go
and make other arrangements
I'm not saying go become a Republican I
don't care what you are but the Democrat
Party it doesn't doesn't work with your
pro-life ethics so but he had but you
know so his message is you're not
welcome but he said with a smile on his
face and so it's okay I guess now this
dynamic of Buddha judge being angry and
spiteful and exclusionary even while
trying to cultivate the opposite kind of
brand and image is even more apparent on
issues of race and so I want to talk
about that there's he did something he
sent out a memo that is it's it's quite
easily one of the most racist things
we've seen an American politician do in
many years and I'm not exaggerating
we're to talk about that just a second
first a word from ancestry.com you know
there are many paths to finding your
family story
whichever way you choose tracing your
family generation back with with a
family tree or uncovering your ethnicity
with ancestry DNA it's it's easy to get
started with ancestry and ancestry DNA
test tells you where your ancestors are
from and ancestries billions of records
and millions of family trees let you
discover their personal stories you
could find an infamous relative if you
don't have enough of those already
currently living or perhaps a photo of
your great-grandma as a little girl
whatever you find it's sure to change
the whole way you look at your family
history in the way that you look at
yourself because you're learning
something not just about your family but
by learning something about your family
you're learning something about yourself
ancestry DNA can reveal ethnic origins
and provide historical details that
bring unique family stories to life
ancestry DNA doesn't just tell you which
countries you're from but it also
pinpoint the specific regions within
them giving you insightful Geographic
details about your origin so it really
gets into the to the nitty gritty goes
it goes into into great details it's not
just broad strokes you're gonna learn
very specific information I've done this
myself and first I have to tell you it's
really easy and very simple to do
quicker than I expected not knowing
anything about it I thought it would be
a more a longer sort of more drawn out
process but sending in the test very
easy to get it back much quicker than
you think
and I've been stunned frankly to see my
own past my own history my my life come
to life and for me
III very much had this feeling of
gratitude seeing all that had to happen
before me when you think about how
incredibly improbable it is that you
exist because all of these many many
many couplings had to happen in order
for you as you are to come into
existence and so that's one thing that
ancestry lays out for you and I just
find it pretty pretty remarkable and
and worthwhile start exploring your
family story today head to my URL at
ancestry.com slash Matt that's
ancestry.com slash Matt to get your
ancestry DNA kit and start your free
trial that's ancestry.com slash Matt
ancestry.com slash Matt's tooties but
Lee time ATT okay now back to the
spiteful and exclusionary mayor Pete
case in point the Buddha judge campaign
sent around a survey to their staff a
few days ago and Reid Epstein reporter
for The New York Times has more
information about the survey so I want
to take a look at this here's the
screenshot of his tweet about it
Epstein reports Buddha judge staffers
circulated a survey of microaggressions
on the campaign please only fill out
this survey if you identify as a person
of color
it reads answers quote will be used to
inform our white colleagues about
privilege and microaggressions and then
you can see the actual survey they're
not sure if it's too small to read it
says you know yes please only fill out
the survey if you identify as a person
of color so and so forth and then it
says in the workplace have you ever
experienced the following from a white
colleague been interrupted / talked over
left off a relevant email chain not
invited to a meeting directly related to
your job idea was ignored / dismissed
without explanation someone else taking
credit for your idea or insight even
accidentally been called the name of a
different staff member of color all of
the above or other so you can fill in
your complaints if they weren't included
on the checklist and then there's a next
part where it's sort of more essay type
questions where you can elaborate says
what does good Ally ship look like to
you what does good Ally ship feel like
what does bad Ally ship look like to you
what doesn't bad Ally ship feel like
what does Ally ship in the workplace
look like to you what does it feel like
this starting to feel a little bit
redundant think of a moment or moments
during which you experience
microaggressions without naming names of
the people can you name the
microaggression describe those moments
what was the physical environment like
if it happened in in the if it happened
in the ether for example in slack email
or text identify that were there
witnesses to it and if so do you think
they recognized it
you know microaggressions in the ether
you got to look out for that that's
that's really the main place if you're
in the ether
now I spent a lot of time in the ether
right and that's where the
microaggressions really come on pretty
hard okay there's so much going on here
I don't even know where to begin but
first of all notice the word identify
there identify as a person of color what
does that mean well we know what it
means anytime somebody on the Left uses
the identify as qualifier what is meant
is anyone who is this or anyone who has
delusions of being this so Budaj is
leaving the door open for the rachel
dolezal of the world he's saying that
even our race is subject to feelings and
we can change our race based on how we
feel which if we can do that with sex of
course we can do it with race making
race fluid and subjective is much less
extreme than making sex fluid and
subjective because in fact race is in a
way a fluid thing now it's not so fluid
that you can decide thirty-two years
into your life that you want to be a
different race it's not that fluid but
but it is it is a there's a there is an
actual spectrum of race and ethnicity
whereas there isn't one with sex
so if you're gonna do it with sex and of
course you can do with race and and it's
not a surprise then that the left is
doing this but I do want to point out
that they are doing it they they they
are now officially making even race and
identify as sort of thing and then also
just the the phrase person of color
after that I know that Buddha judge
didn't invent this phrase himself he's
dutifully using the phrase because it is
the it is the politically correct phrase
of the moment it'll change yeah five
five years from now or two years from
now or six months from now it'll be a
different phrase and all of a sudden if
you use that phrase you're a racist but
right now this is the phrase to use but
it's it's it's sort of a nonsensical
phrase because it includes everybody
person of color Caucasians contrary to
popular belief we are not colourless
translucent monstrosities okay I know
that I personally as a white person of
Irish ancestry I may get close to that
but I'm not actually that but we do have
color on our skins and and it's not even
like we have less color that doesn't
make any sense it's not less color it's
not even a different color it's just a
different shade of brown that's what we
all are we're all different shades of
brown so once again the politically
correct term actually causes more
division and more segregation which
which which in fact is what it's
intended to do because it sets up this
dichotomy of people with color and
people without color even though that
category doesn't exist imagine what you
would think okay what would you picture
if you were a space alien another galaxy
and you were eavesdropping on our radio
transmissions and you kept hearing about
people of color who exist on earth as
opposed to other Earthlings who
apparently have no color so you would
imagine that there must be on earth this
group of Earthlings who are like ghostly
apparitions wandering the countryside no
color like walking jellyfish almost
entirely see-through that's what you
imagine that's that that's the image you
would have in your head anyway then you
get to the actual survey a survey about
how his staff feels
survey about the about their fragile
emotional states but he clarifies at the
outset if you're white I don't give a
damn I don't want to hear about it I
don't care about your experiences
how is this not racist as hell
we how is it even legal
forget about ethical how is it given all
the laws governing these sorts of things
is it actually legal for an employer to
send out a survey asking his employees
have you ever had problems with people
of this particular race think about that
for a second just think about what this
is what what's going on here this is
what he asked
he starts out if you're if you're this
race I don't want to hear from you shut
up okay people this of the other race
over here have you had any trouble with
these folks with these people how is
that again is it even legal to do that
it feels like it's probably not imagine
imagine this survey but with black
colleague instead of white
imagine a survey that begins with this
is a survey for white people if you're
black please we don't we don't want you
to fill it out and then it begins with
to attend you white people have you had
any problems with your black colleagues
here's a list of problems and you might
have had with them imagine a survey like
that I'm hatching the reaction it's
literally unimaginable because it would
never happen but think about it just for
a second think about the reaction in our
culture to something like that
they're a Republican and you could say
well Budaj is white so it's okay okay
well fine imagine a republic Republican
sending a survey like that about his
black employees to his white I mean it's
it's the it would be a an explosion of
outrage unlike anything we've seen in
recent years but somehow it's supposed
to be okay in the reverse somehow this
kind of grotesque explicit racism is
supposed to for some reason somehow be
okay nobody can explain why it's okay
nobody can explain that there's this
there's this constant double standard
with racial issues no one can explain
the double standard or justify it there
is no justification it's obviously a
hypocritical double standard but the
answer is well deal with it and then
what are the questions what are these
horrible things that these people of
color on the staff are experiencing at
the hands of their translucent ghostly
counterparts well a whole bunch of stuff
that all adult humans experience all the
time a whole bunch of stuff that all
this all just simply comes with the
territory when you're a grown up in
modern society I was interrupted I
wasn't invited to a meeting of what
persecution what a burden first of all
not being invited to a meeting is a
blessing who complains about not being
invited to a meeting when I don't get
invited to meetings I throw a party it's
the greatest thing in the world to not
have to go to a meeting but yes what a
you are the only person ever in history
to experience such trials people are so
desperate for persecution that they
cling to these minor social miscues and
annoyances that's what is being talked
over that happens to everyone literally
every single day it happens to every
person if during that their their time
during the day they speak and have
conversations with other people if you
do that it is 100 cent guaranteed you're
gonna be talked over at some point
probably multiple times it happens to
everybody so we take these really super
minor we call them micro a
microaggression well it's that that
actually is an apt phrase it is micro it
is microscopic and what you're doing is
you're taking this a micro Scotty could
barely even see it you're taking with
tweezers out of a petri dish this
microscopic little tiny small social
annoyance and you're lifting it up it's
like look what happened to me but what
we do is we take these things
turn them into a race thing or a gender
thing isn't this a you know feminist
complain about this - oh I'm talked over
in meetings meanwhile it happens to
everyone so okay if if you're talked
over or not invited to a meeting and
then you say oh it's racism or oh it's
sexism well what about what it happens
to a white man how do you explain that
you're not gonna call it racism or
sexism so in that case it's just stuff
that's in that case you're gonna say
well it just happens so why couldn't
just happen over here every time it
happens here it's racism or sexism but
what it happens here every single time
it's an oculus does that actually make
sense logically no by the way before we
we move on and stop picking on Buddha
judge speaking before about the person
of color phrase I should mention that
Buddha judge thought did think of an
even more bizarre variation of person of
color and anyway I'd have to play this
for you listen to this video just follow
up on that it seems like some of the
concerns within your staff have to do
with how they are personally affected by
your inability to make movement with
voters of color and some of the
controversies that have popped up over
the last several months what have you
done personally to address some of those
concerns from your own staff who have to
answer to their friends and their
families about why they support you the
president first of all I just want to
say I'm so thankful to staff of color we
bring so much to this campaign
surrogates staff and supporters who put
a lot on the line
in their own lives when they decide that
they're part of this effort
I think we're part of it because we
share the same values and because we
share the same goal of what we want to
do in this campaign and for the
presidency and I want everyone on our
team to know that I'm proud of them that
I'm thankful for them and I support them
staff of color staff of color that
sounds like it sounds like something a
flamboyant wizard might wield against
his adversaries the staff of color now
do you think staff of color it but do
you think any of this all the stuff that
Budaj is doing using phrases like staff
of color and sending out these racist
memos to fighting his own staff down
according to their race you think any of
this is is succeeding and in doing what
it's supposed to do which is impress the
radical left that's what he's trying to
do obviously he's trying to impress them
and you think any of us is exceeding you
think the left do you think the radical
left they're seeing all this and they're
going wow gee this fella gets it he's
not like those other white folks do you
think that's happening no it's not it's
not having the reaction generally from
the left all of this has been you know
not good enough not enough or I've seen
some some of them saying this is
actually insulting and demeaning which
it is in fact because not only with a
member like this not only is it racist
to the white people but it's patronizing
and paternalistic to the quote people of
color or the staff of color but so
not even succeeded
and this is the same theme we always go
back to where you've got people
embarrassing themselves humiliating
themselves groveling saying all these
things they don't believe you think you
think people judge actually think cares
about microaggressions or you think
that's a phrase he would ever really
sincerely authentically use on his own
no of course not that there are about 15
people in in the whole country who
really think that microaggressions exist
at all 15 of them have blue hair and
their College sophomores okay
everybody else no one else actually it
with so many things on the left that
they get away with
it's almost nobody really believes it
another of course big example with the
gender stuff how many people really
actually honestly believe that the you
know muscle-bound male running and the
girls track to him is really a girl in
some mysterious mystical way how many
people really believe that really in
their in their heart of hearts believe
it I think again it's the 15 blue-haired
College sophomores and no one else but
they get away with it because we're all
expected to go along with things that we
don't believe
and people judge is more than happy to
do that because he is a coward alright
let's go to well before we move on we'll
check in with our friends over at ring
there's nothing more important in your
home than feeling safe that's that's
that's really the one of the primary the
the main point of having home actually
is to is to be safe and to be sheltered
that's why you have the home and so to
be in your home and not feel safe I
think can be a real emotional burden and
that's why ring is so important rings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or surprise visitor you're
gonna get an alert you'll be able to see
it
you could be 2,000 miles away and you're
gonna know that there's somebody at your
house and that's thanks to the HD video
and two-way audio features on the ring
device which yes also not only can you
see that there's air but you can speak
to them as well
and there's a lot that comes with that
convenience is a big thing but it's not
all about safety of course it's also
just sometimes you can't get to the door
you could talk to the person who's at
the door and it's a convenience thing
but then it's it's peace of mind as well
and for me
we have rang we've got multiple ringing
devices in our home and so it's it's
just a peace of mind knowing that I can
keep an eye on things and that I have
that sort of control over my own house
as a subscriber you have a special offer
on a ring welcome kit available right
now at ring comm slash Walsh the kit
includes a video doorbell of a chime Pro
which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go to ring comma slash Walsh
that's ring comm slash Walsh ok so I
finally have a chance to talk about this
I've been meaning to talk about it for a
few days now Paulo White's prosperity
gospel televangelist theological scam
artists also spiritual advisor to the
president unfortunately was recently
doing some preaching and had some
interesting things to say including
appearing to pray for miscarriages
although she says it was taken out of
context but let's play the clip first
and then we'll talk about her context
for this hey hey
we interrupt that which is been deployed
to hurt the church in this season that
which has been deployed to hurt this
nation in the name of Jesus forgive us
for our sins come on I need you guys to
pray
we can't throw every surprise from the
witchcraft in the mote green kingdom any
hex any spell any witchcraft any spirit
of control any Jezebel anything that the
enemy desires through spells through
witchcraft through any way that is
manipulation demonic manipulation we
curse that we break it according to the
Word of God in the name of Jesus we come
against the marine kingdom we come
against the animal kingdom any the woman
that rides upon the waters we break the
power in the name of Jesus and we
declare that any strange winds any
strange ones that have been sent to hurt
the church sent against this nation sent
against our president sent against
myself sit against others we break it by
the superior blood of Jesus right now in
the name of Jesus we arrest every
infirmity affliction fatigue weariness
weakness fear sickness any
self-righteousness any self-serving
action God let pride fall let pride fall
let pride fall let pride fall in the
name of Jesus we command all sentient
satanic pregnancies to miscarry right
now we declared that anything that's
been conceived in satanic wounds did
it'll miscarry they will not be able to
carry forth any plan of destruction any
plan of harm
okay she's praying that satanic
pregnancies will miscarry miscarry and
she has she's well she's responded to to
the controversy over these remarks
explaining that it was taken out of
context she wasn't talking about
physical pregnancy she says she meant
spiritual spiritual pregnancy and as in
I guess anyone who's
pregnant with an evil plot that the evil
plot will miscarry this is what she says
quoting her this is how she
contextualized it she said anything that
has been conceived by demonic plans for
it to be canceled and not prevail in
your life that is any plans to hurt
people all right so so that so the The
Satanic pregnancy so Satan then is Satan
is pregnant with plans to harm you and
and she's praying for a miscarriage of
those dastardly plans
listen I here's the thing I believe her
actually I believe her explanation I
hundred percent believe it it doesn't
make sense it's the dumbest clumsiest
crassest metaphor I've ever heard of my
life I mean literally any other imagery
any other words would have been better
to get her point across she chose the
worst possible way to phrase it and a
way that even as metaphor is insensitive
to women who've had miscarriages there's
why evoke that imagery at all
why evoke miscarriage as a positive
thing that you pray for why do that
there's no reason to do it but but I do
believe that that that is what she meant
because it makes even less sense
literally it makes no sense either way
but it makes slightly it's slightly more
nonsensical in a literal way so find
whatever I buy her excuse that was
metaphor of course she said oh she said
she has said a lot of things that are
not metaphor like for example this
wherever I go God rules
when I walk on White House grounds God
walks on White House grounds I had every
right and authority to declare the White
House has holy ground because I was
standing there and where I stand is holy
where she walks is holy where she walks
she herself has the power in herself to
Senta fie any place that she walks but
of course we could spend all day going
through Paula White's various heresies
and blasphemies and and the like the
point is that this person is such a
blatant huckster so explicitly in it for
her own fame and wealth and gain so
damaging to Christianity in so many ways
that she shouldn't have a following at
all we shouldn't be talking about her
satanic pregnancy concept at all because
she shouldn't have any congregation to
say that stuff in front of I think what
Christians what Christians have to think
about and understand is that when we
follow and listen to and give
credibility to and money in a platform
to people like this it's not only
ourselves on our own souls that were
harming we also damage the church as a
whole Christendom as a whole by
elevating these people into visible
positions who are so obviously corrupt
so absurdly obvious in their in their
grift
and people who are who are not Christian
you know they look at someone like Paula
white and they say well yeah see this is
what I'm talking about
this is Christianity this is why I'm not
Christian here's something we should
think about I think I think I think
every Christian should should should
think about this and it's a difficult
thing to think about a difficult thing
to try to persist it's a difficult
perspective to adopt but we should think
okay what if I wasn't Christian what if
I wasn't Christian what if I wasn't
raised in the faith and now I'm looking
as an outside observer I'm looking out
at the scene I'm surveying modern
Christianity guy I have no bias in favor
of it because I wasn't raised with it
and let's say that I don't have any bias
against it particularly either let's
just say I and I was raised kind of
neutral on the subject of Christianity
which a lot of people are I'm coming it
from at it from that perspective with
that mentality and I'm looking at modern
Christianity in America what would I
think
but what I think what would you think
what I look at this landscape replete
with televangelist con artists and hacks
and charlatans and unthinking sheep who
follow these clowns around
these I mean I'm sorry these frankly
idiots that you see in the audience at
these things go clapping and applauding
what I look at that and think wow these
Christians really seem to be onto
something
I've got to play closer attention to
what they're saying would you think that
would you
I wouldn't
I can tell you right now I would I
wouldn't look at modern Christianity
American Christianity from the outside
and think to myself this seems like a
system of thought a belief system that
holds within it the very keys to the
meaning and purpose of life and of the
cosmos I don't think I think that from
that perspective
and we could say all we want no but you
can't that's not fair you can't judge us
by Paula white all right fine I mean we
can say that
there's a lot of Paulo whites out there
maybe they're not all as bad as her but
it's a lot of them and and that's a
problem
and it's a problem we need to be very
much conscious of
I mean it and we you know it's easy for
us to do this with other religions
may we look at Islam for example and we
see how there is obviously a huge
problem with people committing heinous
ly violent acts in the name of Islam and
then we hear Muslims say well but you
can't judge it based on that that's not
you know and and yeah they're they're in
a better position to talk about what
Islam actually teaches them we are we're
not experts on the subject I'm certainly
not but even so from the outside we
listen to that excuse even if it's true
but we listen to and we say yeah I don't
know
well what do people say what do they
think with the poll of whites of the
world
by the way I'm going back to that Paula
white clip again I just want to rewind
the tape when on earth actually played
again but because we've addressed the
miscarriage part I didn't I didn't want
to completely skip over the other thing
she said men she mentioned twice the
marine kingdom the evil spirits of the
marine kingdom she's praying that we
come against the marine kingdom you know
I heard this and I didn't I didn't pick
up on her the first time but I listened
to copilot I listen back to it and I
thought wait wait what marine what is
she talking about
and I I've been a Christian for 33 years
I've been to hundreds of churches in my
day I never heard that before I've never
heard anyone praying against the marine
kingdom and so I looked it up to see
like what is this and apparently this is
a thing among some Christians no no it's
not a thing in any of the churches I've
ever been to thank goodness but it is a
it is actually a thing there are some
who believe in an actual aquatic kingdom
of like monsters and demons who live in
the sea I read somewhere I forget where
I read this but I was reading somewhere
online some website about this and
apparently this includes mermaids
there are satanic mermaids who are part
of this belief that some people believe
that like I mean if you go into the
ocean there's an actual underwater like
Atlantis kind of demonic community
living there and the sea but again this
is the kind of thing it's it's so
embarrassing
and you know this is not a widespread
belief thankfully actually I don't know
how widespread it is I never even heard
of it before but
it's it's it's so stupid and and and and
embarrassing that it does great damage
credibility of the Christian faith okay
now before we move on if you're a
regular listener you've obviously heard
me talked plenty about the pro-life
issue which is the great civil rights
issue of our time Joe Biden says that
transgender rights transgender equality
is the great civil rights issue of our
time I tend to disagree I'd say that the
killing of 60 million human children is
the greatest civil rights issue of our
time and there have been few civil
rights issues in the history of the
human race that I've been as serious as
this when you consider the the death
toll of 60 million but what we know is
that while this is happening and and we
as pro-lifers are doing everything we
can hopefully to oppose it and fight
against it and protect these these
unborn children these victims we know
that the left is going further and
further off the cliff getting more
extreme and more radical and while they
do that they're also working to shut
down the opposition and we've had that
happen to us when ben shapiro spoke at
the march for life last year there were
you know our advertisers being targeted
by left-wing media watchdogs and
pitchfork mobs and we lost a lot of
revenue on top of that it's not the
first time that happened either we're
also not the first targets or the only
targets at all of the left and of the
pro-abortion left especially live action
is one of the biggest voices in the
pro-life movement they've fallen victim
this as well they've had their
advertising efforts restricted or shut
down completely on some platforms
they've been shut Navin kicked off of
some platforms completely and that is
why it's so important that's why we're
so grateful to have you supporting us
and keeping our cameras on our
microphones turned up even when the left
puts pressure on our sponsors even when
they try to shut us down that's why from
now until January 31st a portion of any
daily wire.com membership will be
donated to live action with promo code
live action to support awareness and
education around the world on this issue
so join live action and make your
pro-life voice heard today
right so I thought this was was powerful
I think well I was gonna read some
emails but I think instead I wanted to
talk about this so we'll do this instead
of emails today but you can email the
show Matt wall show at gmail.com I
thought this was powerful me along with
every other person with appalls who saw
it if you haven't seen it I think you
should a segment on ESPN this is Elle
Duncan reacting to Kobe Bryant's death
by sharing a brief story and it's a
story that I think is worth hearing
listen to this I met Kobe one time
backstage at an event for ESPN in New
York and I saw him and I thought oh my
gosh that's Kobe I got to get a picture
for the gram that's the picture I didn't
get it for a few minutes because as I
approached him he immediately commented
on my rather large eight-month pregnant
belly how are you how close are you what
are you having a girl I said and then he
high-fived me girls are the best I asked
him for advice on raising girls seeing
as though he quite famously had 3 at the
time and he said just be grateful that
you've been given that gift because
girls are amazing as their daughter
Bianca was about a year and a half old
at the time so I asked if he wanted more
children and he said that his wife
Vanessa really wanted to try again for a
boy but was sort of jokingly concerned
that it would be another girl and I was
like four girls are you joking like what
would you think how would you feel and
without hesitation he said I would have
five more girls if I could I'm a girl
dad when it came to sports he said that
his oldest daughter was an accomplished
volleyball player and that the youngest
was a toddler so TBD but that middle one
he said that middle one was a monster
she's a beast she's better than I was at
her age she's got it that middle one of
course was Gigi when I reflect on this
tragedy and that half an hour that I
spent with Kobe Bryant two years ago I
suppose that the only small source of
comfort for me is knowing that he died
doing what he loved the most a big dad
being a girl dad now this sparked a girl
dad hashtag hashtag girl dad on social
media with men talking about their
experiences of being fathers of girls
and a little corny admittedly but but
also
that's not a bad things one of the more
wholesome and constructive trends to
gray social media and certainly a nice
change of pace from the usual petty
outrages that suck up all the oxygen
I'll take the corniness every once a
while over over the the petty outrage
that is pretty much seems to be 98% of
the content on social media these days
now as a girl dad myself two daughters
two sons also I can relate and this is
the thing that
haven't been able to get out of my head
the last few days
been thinking did dig Kobe Bryant and
the rest of the people on that chopper
and remember there were nine people so
there were seven others in alongside
Kobe Bryant his daughter but did they
realize what was happening did the
helicopter start going down and they had
a minute or 30 seconds or 15 seconds
where they understood what was happening
and they understood that there's a good
chance they weren't gonna make it it
sounds like the thing maybe just crashed
right into the side of a mountain
because of the fog and you know they
didn't they couldn't see they didn't see
the mountain they crashed into it I
don't know if that's what happened what
happened exactly it sounds like that may
have been what happened and in that case
probably there was no warning no moment
of realization before the end it just
just happened so I don't know but
whether it happened that way or not I
still can't get out of my head the image
of a man sitting there with his daughter
knowing what's going to happen and
knowing that he can't protect her
because as girl dads and boy dads and as
dads in general the thing we want most
is to protect our children that is our
number one goal with respect to our kids
is to protect them not just physically
but emotionally psychologically
spiritually to create security and give
him a secure environment and and to
protect them and to get them into
adulthood safely intact in every sense
of the word so the thought of a man
staring at his little girl looking her
in the eyes knowing that he can't
protect her knowing that pain and death
are coming and he can't stop it that's
that that really gets me and it's
something that I think about I mean I
think about this that sort of as morbid
I tend to be kind of morbid maybe you've
noticed so I was one of the reasons why
my mind went here is because I've
thought about this I've flown with my
kids several times and as a lot of
people have and I think about this every
time I'm on a plane with them plane
starts going down what would I say to my
kids but then I think as I was thinking
about that I realized that all of us all
dads all moms - what we're all in that
situation all the time in a way and this
is why there's always this undercurrent
of sadness and it's it's hard to put
your finger on it's hard to understand
as a parent but I've talked to a lot of
parents that have experienced the same
thing and know what I'm talking about
that even in your happiest moments as a
parent and in some ways especially in
the happiest moments there's the
happiness and the joy but underneath
that there's this bittersweet miss this
this sadness and the sort of longing
that that lies they're barely beneath
the surface all the time and it's hard
exactly why it's there but I think this
is it because we want nothing more than
to protect our children and we would die
to protect them we would do anything for
them
yet we know that our efforts will prove
futile eventually hopefully not in this
tragic dramatic sudden way like it did
sadly for Kobe Bryant and his daughter
but they were made but maybe a will I
mean that could happen to any one of us
at anytime something like that sudden
tragedy but however it happens we know
eventually pain and suffering will come
for our children no matter what this is
guaranteed and we won't be able to stop
it
so you look at your child now if you
have young children especially you look
at your children young and innocent
they haven't suffered yet in life at all
you know there were suffering as when
they want a snack and you won't give it
to them or something but and you think
eventually they're gonna suffer one way
or another not now we hope not soon but
everyone dies everyone suffers everyone
experiences despair and heartbreak and
misery everybody does
no exceptions it's the lot that we have
all it's the is that it's all it for all
of us it is our lot in life and for our
kids as well one day tomorrow maybe or
maybe many tomorrow's from now it will
happen and that reality that
helplessness is I think a source of
great pain for parents we don't dwell on
it we try not to but it's always there
and that's where Parenthood's
bittersweet flavor I think comes from so
I think about Kobe Bryant on a
helicopter with his daughter and maybe
he had a warning maybe he didn't but
either way in microcosm he was in the
same
situation we're all in and not to resort
to cliches but sometimes we're talking
about these sort of things it's
impossible not to resort to cliches
because there's a reason why they're
cliche there's truth to it so the cliche
here is that you know as parents we have
to cherish all the more the moments that
we have with our kids now give them all
the love now all the protection all the
security we can knowing that it won't
last forever
there's a there's a real finitude to it
which is another thing we don't like to
think about I don't like to dwell on or
obsess over and we shouldn't but we
shouldn't forget it either I think so
that's what I was thinking about want to
share on that note a little bit of a sad
note but I think we will wrap it up for
the day thanks for watching and
listening thank you for subscribing if
you don't please subscribe as well and
I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
CNN's Don Lemon and two Talking Heads
sidekicks spend nearly a minute and a
half of airtime laughing about how
stupid they think half of Americans are
we examine why leftists love humanity
but always seem to hate actual humans
then Liberal Democrat Alan Dershowitz
demolishes House Democrats impeachment
case in a little under three minutes
Liz Warren throws a Hail Mary Hillary
threatens to run again and drag queens
story hour is coming to a public school
near you check it out on the Michael
Noel's show